[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so it seemed that we'd all got
used to the idea that rather than there
being a single definitive truth there
are a multiplicity of competing and
alternative perspectives now with the
rise of fate news and publicizing of
blatant lies we want to reassert the
importance of accuracy and truth can we
call out lies and deception while still
allowing for radically different ways of
seeing is there a difference between
truth within a perspective and truths
that extends to all perspectives or
should we simply conclude that
post-modernism and relativism were a
dangerous mistake and so here to discuss
this we have a very lustrous and highly
I'm sure a truthful panel Sacha Golub
here is a senior lecturer at the
Department of Philosophy at King's
College London specializing in modern
European philosophy and he's also the
director of the Centre for philosophy
and visual arts and we have also a weak
force is professor of theoretical
philosophy at Stockholm University and a
member of the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences building on her work in the
space between philosophy of mind
language and epistemology she published
her book alternative facts in 2017 and
Steve fuller here is an academic
specializing in the field of science and
technology studies and his latest work
is entitled post truth knowledge as a
power game and he's a philosophical
defender of post truths and we have here
at the end Peter pomerantsev who's a
Soviet born British journalist and he's
a visiting senior fellow at the
Institute of global affairs at the LSE
and he's co-director there of the arena
program with the stated aim to analyze
and counter the root causes of distorted
information polarization and hate speech
and his
this book is called this is not
propaganda adventures in the war against
reality so that gives you some sense
perhaps of the multiple perspectives of
our panel on this debate so the question
and I'll pose it first to Sasha go love
is can we allow for multiple
perspectives yet
still call out falsehoods and lies Sasha
thank you three minutes on that thanks
your honor first off thanks Ervin for
for coming so what's interesting about
this debate is the way the political and
the conceptual bleed into each other
writes this is a philosophical question
it's also a political question a nice
anecdote that shows that a couple of
years ago is doing some work with a
group that supports the disabled and
particularly disabled refugees and as
you can imagine their politics is very
left-wing and they'd had all these
posters made that they put up they were
kind of plaque hearts that they had made
and they'd had them made about four or
five years ago and one of them said
everyone has their own troops and they
put this up and then they said why
should we be embarrassed about this one
now it sounds kind of rather trumpian
and so they took it down again but when
that had that made that seemed to them
an integral part of a sort of leftist
political program that it was about
hearing the truth of the disadvantage
something like that it's this idea of
multiple truths of everyone having their
own truth where you place that on the
political spectrum may change over time
and it may depend on your other
political commitments
so that's we'll hear a lot more about
the politics obviously on the conceptual
side multiple perspectives are often
going to be a useful thing right you
often have multiple perspectives because
they're different parts of one large
true story so I suppose you're trying to
understand the UK labor market
you've got the perspective of the Bank
of England you've got the perspective of
a small business only you've got the
perspective of a fifty year old woman in
Woking tune trying to find work they've
all got different perspectives we need
all those perspectives because they're
all little glimpses of the big story
having lots of perspectives is perfectly
compatible with having a kind of ranking
and it's perfectly compatible with some
of them not being very good it's
perfectly compatible with some of them
being grossly misleading so at the
moment I've got a good perspective on
you okay I can see you all okay you've
got a good perspective on me now if I
take these off my
spectres got a lot worse can't see you
so well if I come and sit behind or sir
and peer out from behind the chair first
time girl look cool an odd guy but my
perspectives gonna get even worse right
and your perspective for me is probably
going to get even worse in every sense
so you can help me I do have lots of
perspectives and you can have the idea
of a ranking of them that's quite
natural something I think is
particularly important in this debate
and the last thing I'll say is instead
of debunking views by talking about
people's perspectives so this is when
you say you only think that because or
you just believe that because so you
know you only believe in brexit because
you're racist or you only believe in
basic because you don't know the
arguments or you only believe in social
justice because you're a snowflake or
whatever so these because arguments are
basically saying I'm not going to engage
with the views you're putting forward
because I think your perspective is
driving them they're not rationally
defensible views it's your perspective
that's leading you to to this position
and so I'm going to bunk you by pointing
out that perspective and these are
important in a democracy to have these
debunking arguments but also quite
dangerous if you don't use them
carefully because they effectively say
we're not going to engage with the
argument of this group and it's going to
lead very often that group becoming
radically alienated because it's going
to think it's arguments aren't being
heard it's just being dismissed as a
snowflake has a white guy as a racist or
whatever and that group is going to
become radically quite unhappy quite
quickly so multiple perspectives often a
good thing you can rank them and be
careful of these debunking arguments you
only believe it because just you just
think that because of your race your
gender whatever those are often going to
be important but they're also often
gonna be dangerous Thank You Sasha
that's great I'd like to turn now to
thank you now to also for the same
question can we allow for multiple
perspectives yet still call out
falsehoods and lies also thank you yes
so I absolutely think we can if we do it
right so let me start by connecting a
little bit with this comments here
because I think what was good about the
talk about different perspectives was
precisely that it was a way to get more
knowledge to get more
truce as it were so take the classic
case of you know how we describe our
history so if you describe history just
from the perspective of the rulers or
from white man and so on you're going to
get you're going to miss out on a lot of
knowledge you're going to not have
knowledge about what it was like for the
women for the children or for the sake
and so on so the point of adding
perspectives there is to add more
knowledge and that's something we have
this we always have a selection problem
we can't describe everything that
happened in history so we make some
selection and there's always a very big
danger that our selection is very skewed
by our politics or by our backgrounds
and so on and then all this talk other
people coming into the Academy always
talk about bringing in other
perspectives is really really helpful
and we should remember that so that
doesn't that's not in itself saying
there is no truth right but it's just a
way of saying that we need to do this to
get to the truth to get to a rich a
picture of reality that's really
important so that said I think there are
of course situations where you have
incompatible perspectives on the same
thing on the same statement as it were
when we have in contemporary world we
have the I'm talking factual statements
like whether vaccines cause autism and
climate change whether that's caused by
carbon dioxide emissions and so on when
you have those sort of clashes obviously
they can't both be right obviously I say
but it's an analytic philosopher I think
clearly they camp up right truth is a
property of this statement that it has
or doesn't have and so one person is
going to be wrong there it's still
useful of course up to a point to have
different perspectives
why because different perspectives force
us to sharpen our arguments to engage
with possible bias and errors that we
make it's the idea of the good debate of
the good seminar where even though it's
pretty clear that one person has the
better arguments less less sharpen them
less less less check that we haven't
made a mistake in error and we know I
mean there's some nice research showing
indeed that when people
when it comes to confirmation bias for
example which is this tendency we have
we all have to confirm our own views
we're really really bad at getting past
confirmation bias when we do it alone
but when we engage in dialogue with
other peoples that have slightly
different perspectives that are willing
to question us we very quickly can get
past our confirmation bias so different
perspectives can be useful even though
we are in a situation where we can't all
be right just one more thing of course
one thing when people talk about
different perspectives which is also
very legitimate is that we're talking
about people's experiences and of you
know we have different experiences of
the same thing and even when my
experiences are not actually kind of
corresponding to what happened it's
important to bring out what I did
experience because maybe I got very
scared or very upset try to understand
my perspective that's also legitimate
has nothing to do with truth but because
except that of course there are truths
about my experiences that can be very
important to understand me and to
understand the dynamics of what's going
on so that's also one sense in which is
perfectly fine to talk about different
perspectives without losing sight of
truth and knowledge so thank you also to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas